John: Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday.
Wait, what is this background? Am I on a green screen? Am I in Montana?
Hank: Yes, you are.
John: It’s Hank! It's a reunion video! It's happening!
Hank is making his triumphant but temporary
return to vlogbrothers. Hello.
Hank: Hello! I might make another video this week about VidCon.
John: You’re so bad at paternity leave.
Okay, Hank, I got some Question Tuesday questions
from nerdfighters for you.
First, how is Orin doing?
Orin is your son.
Hank: He's good!
He's good. He’s a good baby.
John: So cute!
Hank: He’s very cute.
John: It’s almost unbearable.
Hank: I think he may have smiled at me this morning.
John: Really?
Hank: Maybe.
He might have just been pooping.
John: Hank, why is there no sequel to The
Fault in Our Stars?
Hank: It would have been, I think, maybe not
the happiest book.
John: I also don’t really know how it could’ve
happened, but believe me, people in Hollywood
did make suggestions.
Favorite Disney movie, go!
Hank: Is “Go” a Disney movie?
John: I thought that that was way too dark
to be a Disney movie.
I think it was rated R. I liked the new one
that Lin Manuel Miranda wrote the songs for.
Hank: You know Lin Manuel Miranda wrote a
song for the new Star Wars movie?
*sings*
John: Unfortunately, we don’t have the ability
to clear the rights to that song, but on the
upside, that was not a good enough version
Hank: Yeah! Nobody knows what I was singing.
John: for copyright to come into play.
What is the most surprising—
Hank: Frozen!
John: That’s wasn’t the question.
What is the most surprising thing about having
a baby?
Hank: The noise or the poops.
John: Yes.
Hank: Like, literally surprising
John: Sonic
Hank: like I’ll be like, “Huaahh!!”
Within the first day of Orin being home
John: Yeah.
Hank: he—he pooped with his diaper off
while I was changing it.
John: Oh Hank, that’s a rookie error.
Hank: I’m a rookie.
John: I know.
Henry pooped on me so many times.
Alice pooped on me never, because I would
go in with like seven diapers.
I’d be wearing like a diaper suit of armor.
Hank: I went ahead and tried to catch it with
my hand.
John: Nope.
Hank: I was like, “Euugh!!”
John: Switch glasses.
Hank: Every time we do this, I’m like, yours
are dirty.
John: Yeah, that’s how I like to see the world:
through smudged lenses.
Hank: This eye is pretty much exactly the
same.
John: Oh yeah. Wow.
The left eye is the exact sa—it’s almost
like we’re brothers.
If you could take one book to a desert island,
what book would it be?
I’ve been thinking a lot about this question.
Hank: And just like leave it there so no one
could ever read it again?
John: No!
Hank: Ayn Rand’s The Fountainhead.
John: Here is my idea: It’s a book where
if you read it forwards, all the—it’s
just the collected works of Shakespeare.
So it’s rich, it’s complicated, it’s
beautiful, and then if you read it backwards,
like the back sides of the pages
Hank: Okay.
John: are a survival guide for how to live
on a desert island.
Hank: I was gonna go with The Kingkiller
trilogy by Patrick Rothfuss, even though the
last book isn’t out yet, ‘cause I—if
I was gonna get stuck on a desert island,
I better have that third book.
John: I was gonna say, how terrible would
it be?
You know what would happen, though, because
Pat Rothfuss is such a great guy, you wouldn’t
get to leave the desert island, but an airplane
would fly over, drop the third book when it comes out
Hank: Yeah.
John: and just wave goodbye to you.
Hank: Yeah, like a bottle of water.
John: And you’d be like, “That’s all
I needed, thanks!”
Hank, do you have any self-care advice?
Hank: I have lots, but self-care bunny has
better self-care advice than I do.
John: Yeah, self-care bunny is just here to
remind you to be nice to yourself.
Yeah, what did we learn from Nathan Zed’s
video?
You are a good burrito.
Hank: Not the best burrito.
John: You don’t have to be the best, okay,
stop putting so much pressure on yourself.
You’re a really good burrito.
Hank: There’s no best burrito.
John: That’s right.
There’s only different kinds of good burritos.
That’s true, actually.
Hank: Yeah.
John: That’s true on many levels.
Alright Hank, write an autobiography in five
words.
I guess mine would probably be, “Is this
mole a concern?”
I wrote, “He made stuff with John.”
John: Oh God, that’s so nice!
Hank, thanks for taking time away from your
baby to make a Question Tuesday video.
Hank: Thank Katherine.
John: I will see you right now.
Bye.
Why are—what—when did this become a thing? What? What?
Do you know Alice does that?
Hank: Thumbs up?
John: Yeah, whenever you’re like, “Hey,
Alice smile!”
She doesn’t smile, but she’s like…
Hank: That’s great!